DISMISSED THE STORY AND SAYS, NO
COMMENT.
WE'RE NOT GOING THERE.
HOW MANY TIMES HAS THE  "NEW
YORK TIMES" GOTTEN IT WRONG?
IF THE TEXT MESSAGES DON'T PUT
IT OVER THE TOP FOR THOSE THAT
COLLUSION NARRATIVE I DON'T KNOW
WHAT WILL.
YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> NOTHING, SEAN.
SIMPLY PUT, ONE OF THE MOST
SENIOR AGENTS OF THE FBI
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
HILARY-SERVER GATE INVESTIGATION
AND PUT IT IN A TEXT MESSAGE TO
HIS LOVER, I'M GOING GIVE HILARY
SPECIAL TREATMENT BECAUSE, HEY,
SHE MAY BE THE NEXT PRESIDENT.
THAT'S THE DEFINITION OF THE
PERVERSION OF JUSTICE.
THAT'S THE DEFINITION OF
CORRUPTION.
AND NOT SURPRISINGLY, THE DAILY
BEAT IS ALREADY BEHIND THE CURB.
WE KNOW ABOUT COMEY AND STRZOK
12 PEOPLE -- 12 PEOPLE IN THIS
>> Sean: ARE THESE PEOPLE
MENTIONED IN THE MEMO.
>> THE MEMO IS THE TIP OF THE
ICEBERG AND I'M WORRIED BECAUSE
THE DOJ DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
STRATEGIC COMMUNICATIONS.
IF THEY DON'T RELEASE IT THEY'LL
LOSE THE WAR AND THEY'VE BEEN
DILIGENT AND CAUTIOUS.
YOU SEE SCHIFF OUT THERE ALREADY
SPINNING.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE TAKING WEEKS
AND MONTHS TO GET EVERYTHING
DOUBLE CHECKED.
THEY'LL LOSE THE COMMUNICATIONS
WAR AND THE CONSPIRACY WILL
CONTINUE BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE,
SHAWN
SHAW
HAW
THEIR BADGE AND GUN AND WALKED
OUT OF THE HOOVER BUILDING
MONTHS AGO.
>> Sean: HOW IS IT POSSIBLE,
HERMAN CAIN, SEBASTIAN RAISE AS
A GOOD POINT, HOW DO THEY STILL
HAVE JOBS?
HOW DOES McCABE STILL HAVE A JOB
AND JAMES COMEY IS NOT UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE?
>> IT'S POSSIBLE BECAUSE OF THE
METHODS THEY KNOW THEY CAN USE
TO CREATE BARRIERS.
NUMBER ONE, SOMEBODY SHOULD GO
TO JAIL.
I AGREE WITH DR. GORKA.
YES, THE REPUBLICANS NEED TO
INSIST.
ALL YOUR VIEWERS, YOU SHOULD
INSIST TO YOUR REPRESENTATIVES
AND SENATORS, RELEASE THE MEMO.
THE REASON MOST OF THE DEMOCRATS
ON THE INTELLIGENCE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE DIDN'T WANT TO READ IT
IS BECAUSE THEY KNOW IT HAS
DAMAGING INFORMATION.
WON'T BE ABLE TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS AND LET'S FACE
IT, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
PAYING FOR THIS.
WE DESERVE TRANSPARENCY AND THE
"T" IS TRUTH.
>> Sean: LET'S RELEASE THEM ALL.
IT'S SIMPLE.
THEY HAVE SOMETHING TO HIDE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND FROM THE
PUBLIC AND THEY NEED TO RELEASE
THE MEMOS AND RELEASE THE MEMO.
THAT'S PURE AND SIMPLE.
>> Sean: RELEASE THE MEMO AND
THE TEXT.
DR. GORKA, I KNOW IT GETS
CONFUSING, I CAN PUT THEM BACK
ON THE SCREEN AS YOU'RE TALK BUT
DID YOU LOOK AT WHAT STRZOK AND
PAGE ARE SAYING TO EACH OTHER.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE TO ME THAT ALL
THIS HAPPENED, THEY STILL HAVE A
JOB.
NOW, THEY WANTED TO PROTECT
COLMEY, PAGE, STRZOK AND LYNCH
KNEW SHE WON'T GOING TO BE
INDICTED.
THAT'S OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
THAT'S A FELONY AND EVEN COMEY
SAID IT AND IT GETS WORSE AND
DESTROYING 33,000 SUBPOENAED
E-MAILS AND THEN ACID WATCHING
AND BLEACHING THE HARD DRIVE TO
YOU NEVER FIND THEM AGAIN.
YOU'RE TRYING TO OBSTRUCT
JUSTICE?
>> SEAN, YOU'VE OUTLINED WHAT
HILARY DID AND THEY'RE ALL
FELONIES.
THE PRIVATE SERVER, THE
ACTIVITIES.
WE KNOW SHE'S A CRIMINAL AND HAD
ACOME
ACOM
ACCOMPLICES BUT THE FBI
SHE WASN'T SWORN UNDER OATH AND
THE LAP STOPS WERE DESTROYED BY
THE FBI, NOT HILARY.
THEY ALLOWED HER BEST FRIEND,
WHO IS ALSO A SUSPECT, TO ACT AS
HER COUNSEL IN THAT INTERVIEW.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
THAT HAPPENED BECAUSE THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION ALLOWED IT TO
HAPPEN AND THE RIGHT NAME FOR
ALL OF THIS IS OBAMA-GATE.
IF HE DOESN'T ALLOW IT TO
HAPPEN, IT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
>> Sean: I WILL TELL YOU, I
NEVER THOUGHT HERMAN KAIN IN MY
LIFE TIME PEOPLE OF THIS LEVEL
OF POWER CAN USE A BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR PHONY DOSSIER OF
HILLARY CLINTON TO GET A FISA
WARRANT -- FIRST TO LIE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND PROPGANDIZE
WITH RUSSIAN LIES AND USE THAT
DOSSIER TO GET A FISA WARRANT TO
SPY ON A CANDIDATE IN A
PRESIDENTIAL YEAR AND UNDERMINE
A PRESIDENT-ELECT.
THIS IS NOT A BANANA REPUBLIC
BUT IT'S THE STUFF OF A BANANA
REPUBLIC.
>> SEAN, MY LAST WORD IS SIMPLY
WHEN.
AND I WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE, DUE
JUST BASED UPON THE INFORMATION
E-MAILS, SOMEBODY IS GOING TO
JAIL AND THEY SHOULD.
>> Sean: I HAVE NO DOUBT IF WE
HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW